c'est pas très frais et je vais rajouter
quelques glaçons ce sera mieux
c'est étonnant quand j'ai mis le bac à
glaçons au congélateur les cubes n'était
pas tout à fait plein et là ça déborde
c'est ce que les scientifiques appellent
une anomalie
guy l'atome et rick joseph ça jette un
froid
elle est facile celle là mais pas de
panique en général quand un corps passe
de l'état liquide à l'état solide son
volume diminue les molécules qui le
composent ajoutée et désordonnée qu'en
la matière se présente à l'état liquide
serez agences et occupe à vos le moins
grand quand elle passe à l'état solide
comme si tout le monde reprenait sa
place c'est le cas des métaux notamment
du fer ou de l'acier sous l'effet de la
chaleur
la matière se ramollit fini par se
liquéfier opérations pendant laquelle le
métal prend du volume
avant de se rétracter quand ils se re
france ce phénomène a pendant longtemps
été utilisées pour assembler des pièces
métalliques c'est le cas des 18000
éléments qui composent la tour eiffel
qui ont été assemblées grâce à des rives
et des clous chauffé à blanc glisser
dans des trous aménagés dans les pièces
dont on peut écraser la pointe étant
donné que le clou a été chauffé à blanc
et que la matière est devenu plus dutil
en refroidissant le métal se contracte
et le river sert les deux pièces
métalliques
l'une contre l'autre alors ce type de
river n'est plus utilisé depuis très
longtemps ils ont été remplacés par des
vis et des écrous enfin je vous raconte
tout ça juste pour vous rafraîchir la
mémoire parce qu'en fait on est là pour
parler de gaza pourquoi occupe-t-il
davantage de volume que l'eau liquide
c'est à cause de la structure de la
molécule d'eau h2o un atome d'oxygène
auquel sont liés deux atomes d'hydrogène
ces atomes possède une charge électrique
négatif pour l'oxygène positive pour
l'hydrogène
concrètement ces atomes s'attire les uns
les autres et du cou et les molécules
d'eau s'attire les unes les autres en
physique on parle de liaison hydrogène
ces liaisons existe bien quand l'eau est
liquide mais les molécules sont
tellement agité qu'elles sont
complètement tordus les liaisons
al'inverse quand la température passe en
dessous de zéro degré tout se fige les
reliques hull sont beaucoup moins agitée
elle se lie les unes aux autres en
formant
des hexagones qu'ils occupent davantage
des espaces que le cas au précédent ça
va ça chauffe patron alors on peut
continuer et on va faire plus léger au
sens propre du terme
à cause de cette particularité physico
chimiques
la glace est moins dense que l'eau
liquide sa masse volumique est moins
élevé tenez comparons ces deux bons
coups ils contiennent tous les deux un
litre 1 litre de glace et un litre d'eau
liquide 1 litre de grâce à une masse de
910 grammes alors qu'un litre d'eau très
vivace de milgram
on peut aussi prendre les choses dans
l'autre sens
à masse égale la glace occupe un plus
grand volume que l'eau liquide c'est
pour cette raison que la glace flotte à
la surface de l'eau et c'est aussi pour
cette raison que l'eau ne déborde pas
quand le glaçon font en fait le volume
du glaçon immergé correspond exactement
au volume d'eau obtenus lorsque le
glaçon aura totalement fondu qui a
inventé la machine à glaçons plusieurs
noms circulent dont celui d'un français
ferdinand carré et ce n'est pas pour
cette raison que les premiers de façon
avec une forme de cube
une vraie tête de premier de la glace
vous trouvez pas il présente sa machine
à l'exposition universelle de londres
en 1862 elle produit des pannes glace
qui sont ensuite débité à la vente
évidemment besoin de place pour la loger
il faut attendre le début du 20ème
siècle pour qu'apparaissent les
premières machines domestiques et ce
n'est qu'au début des années 1950 que
les ménages s'équipent de réfrigérateurs
équipé d'un compartiment freezer encore
un peu l'histoire
[Musique]
avant la machine de ferdinand carré il
fallait aller chercher la glace sur les
glaciers des montagnes où la récupérer
l'hiver sur les cours d'eau gelée le nom
de cette station du métro parisien
rappelle cette activité autrefois le
quartier était traversé par une rivière
la bièvre qui est aujourd'hui enterrée
l'hiver ont récupéré la glace et on la
stocker dans des puits qu'on appelait
des glacières ce qui permettait de
conserver la glace et d'en avoir
pendant tout l'été bon pour ça que je
traîne bon oui était temps que ça se
termine sa fonderie qui agace gâteau
elle ramène aux dégâts sont à très
bientôt
et surtout n'oubliez pas nous on est
confiné mais en restant bien quand j'ai
mis le bac à glaçons congélateur les
cubes n'était pas tout à fait plus
talent a fait plein des vins de glace
qui sont en dessous des bitumes parti
vert ok
[Musique]